house of the dragon comes out august
21st and i've seen people who are either
willing to give the show a try or people
that are really cynical towards the
world of ice and fire and don't want to
watch the show from how much season 8
shattered them which feels bad man but
right away for people in that camp david
benioff and dan weiss the prior genres
of game of thrones aren't involved in
the creative process for house of the
dragon at all so it's a different
creative team with different writers the
two show runners for the show are ryan j
condell and miguel sapochnick for anyone
who isn't familiar with miguel he
directed episodes like hard home wins of
winter in the battle of the bastards so
him being a shore runner to me is great
and is essentially cherry picking the
best talent from game of thrones then on
the flip side i'm more worried about
ryan kandel mainly because this guy has
written rampage and hercules which are
two critically panned movies rampage in
particular is a movie where the rock is
friends with a giant gorilla and they
fight other big animals in a city so
yeah
and trusting him as one of the shriners
in him writing four of the episodes
definitely has me a bit worried this
kind of reminds me of david benioff who
before working on game of thrones made
x-men origins which is one of the worst
marvel movies so hopefully ryan condell
is much better at writing more dramatic
material than blockbuster popcorn movies
then the rest of the writers for the
show are pretty experienced writing
television so it's hard to judge how
well they will do and on the subject for
writing i think one of the most
reassuring aspects is that the source
material for house of the dragon is
based on fire and blood and it's
finished the main issue with the game of
thrones is that george r martin didn't
finish the last two books which led to
david and dan having to match the
quality from the first four seasons for
the later ones which was practically
impossible for house of the dragon
though we don't have to worry about that
because george r martin already wrote
the ending however there is one aspect
about fire and blood in terms of
translation from source material to
screen that can be worrisome which is
the fact that fire and blood is
primarily a telling of events with very
little dialogue and characterization as
a comparison the books for game of
thrones have internal point of view
chapters that are able to thoroughly
develop characters but for fire and
blood
it's mostly just a maester explaining
what happened in the past so what this
means for the tv show is that there will
probably need to be a lot more
characterization and dialogue that isn't
originally in the book because a tv show
needs to have consistent dialogue and
fully realized characters to keep
viewers engaged for game of thrones a
lot of the original dialogue in the
later seasons that david and dan wrote
was terrible and it stood out like a
sore thumb in comparison to george's
dialogue i know there will be different
writers for house of the dragon but
they'll also all have to deliver
consistent high quality dialogue to fill
in the gaps created by the tv show
format so it could either be a glaring
difference or it can perfectly blend in
and you won't notice what's original and
what's new and obviously the action will
be very well executed because miguel
sapochnick is a master at that we'll
just have to wait and see if the
dialogue scenes are as good as game of
thrones looking at some other people
behind the scenes working on house of
the dragon we have the return of rameen
jawadi which is fantastic because that
was the one aspect of game of thrones
that did not drop in quality at all and
if anything he did even better through
the course of the show so i'm really
excited to see him return and i hope he
creates more original work for the show
and they don't just reuse a lot of the
themes from a game of thrones if that
happens then that would be really sad
but i would be surprised if they did
that then i was going to mention the
cinematographer given that the footage
they showed off so far looks great and
atmospheric but for some reason i
physically can't find out who the dp is
on the show but regardless it's hbo and
essentially all of their shows look
outstanding next we have the cast which
also makes me excited matt smith is one
of the leads playing damon targaryen and
he's an actor that can be very likable
charismatic and despite having those
traits he has a lot of range and can
pull off some serious material as well
it's just a little hard to judge him
currently given that he hasn't had the
best luck in picking movies
morbius but there's a lot of past work
that cements him as a good actor then
patty considine as viscera's targaryen i
haven't seen him in a single role that i
disliked and he was a part of the
cornetto trilogy so that makes him
goaded olivia cook is a great up and
coming-ish actor and i loved her work in
sound of metal and thoroughbreds her
eyes in particular feel extremely
expressive and makes her very
sympathetic those are the three main
actors that i've seen a lot before and
there are a few other highlights that
i've seen briefly like graham mctavish
rhysaphon and jefferson hall which for
jefferson hall it's kind of weird that
he's getting casted as a lannister when
he dies in season one of game of thrones
playing hue of the veil so i doubt there
will be any explanation for that i
assume the casting director thought we
wouldn't notice thought we wouldn't
notice
but we did then for the rest of the cast
i'm excited to see how they do one more
great aspect that this show has over
game of thrones is that the overall ip
george has created is a lot more
valuable now going into the first season
of game of thrones the show had a pretty
small budget and the creators were
forced to cut out a lot of content which
also led to issues down the line because
that cut content early on exponentially
blossoms into differing narratives in
regards to cutting characters and plot
lines like as an example the producers
were really close to cutting out rickon
stark which is mind-boggling that that
almost happened on top of the fact that
game of thrones was trying to show an
entire war of the five kings so imagine
if the first season of game of thrones
had the budget of what house of the
dragon had for their first season so
since house of the dragon has a bigger
budget they won't need to make excessive
sacrifices and they won't have to shy
away from certain cool sequences because
of budgetary issues that doesn't mean
they have an infinite budget but the
creators have a lot more freedom in
telling the best story they possibly can
thus upping the potential for the show
but this does bring one minor downside
from that fact which is hopefully they
don't focus too much on action and
actually take time for great dialogue
scenes in character building because
that was one thing the first few seasons
of game of thrones were forced to do
given that they couldn't do a lot of
battles a scene like robert and cersei
talking about their marriage was
improvised by david and dan given that
they didn't have enough scenes for one
of their episodes so because of a bigger
budget it could also lead to some minor
laziness from a creative perspective
since it doesn't force the writers to
dig deep with their characters on a
smaller scale and again this isn't
guaranteed to happen thanks for watching
and i'll probably be covering the show
weekly with episodic reviews
you